with e3 2016 right around the corner The
Witcher developer CD Projekt RED has now
confirmed that its upcoming dystopian
RPG cyberpunk 2077 will not be at the
show I'm Kate and this is your gamespot
news update we still have a lot of work
to do with cyberpunk CD Projekt RED boss
march in a winski told Eurogamer it
might happen that we will be at e3 and
we will show something at e3 but I just
want to make it clear it's not cyberpunk
cyberpunk 2077 is currently scheduled to
launch sometime in the 20 17 to 20 21
window so what might the mystery game be
it could be the unannounced title that
CD Projekt RED first talked about
earlier this year this game expected to
launch or at least be discussed in 2016
is described as a new type of video game
format previously unexplored by the
studio asked if it's this game the CD
Projekt RED will show at e3 a when ski
said we will see the site also press
about whether or not this game was
related to the witcher series time will
tell a winski said what kind of game are
you hoping to see from CD Projekt right
at e3 this year let me know in the
comments or come and find me on Twitter
I'm at how not to draw thanks for
watching and fro your gaming and
entertainment news keep it gamespot
you